le site on va
on va y croire donc alors qu'elle est de
l'est de lever je souhaiterais ne pas
évoquer sa en ces temps difficiles donc
l'amour l'amour là mort le pouvoir régis
par la violence ceci est l'essence même
de la tragédie
et dollars madame formateur
horner apte à chaque achat film adam où
seuls à damas à l'arrière qui ne
traitent pas de l'amour là mort le
pouvoir qui sont régis par la violence
c'est aristote donc
les gens on a évoqué bribes évidemment
et ce n'est pas par hasard parce que sur
ces plans là il était fondateur quand on
était enfant né
dans un milieu social
modeste pour ne pas dire
défavorisés il y avait un labyrinthe
devant nous
dans quelle direction
devons-nous aller
il y en avait 2 3 m la va vite et cela
aussi vite et crée le vice et
l'attentisme bâle lausanne
qui se rejoint un peu avec le rift et où
elle à
l'éducation bema nano l'école nous
offrez
de l'éducation de luz mal mais ce qui
est important c'est que tout le monde
était sérieux moralité sérieux dans
laquelle sérieuse
le lacet stallman ces lieux cantina
qu'un sérieux
nous étions tous pauvres c'était lob de
l'indépendance des années 60
et
du coup faisant partie de trop programme
pédagogique on avait l'activité
théâtrale et l'activité musicale et
l'activité sportive évidemment et donc
c'est ça qui qui nous a poussés dans ce
chemin là c'est ça qui nous a sauvés
sauver des générations des générations
c'est la pratique de théâtre c'est la
pratique de texte majeur c'est la
pratique
des valeurs humaines l'amour là mort le
pouvoir régis par la violence nous avons
appris aussi l'abstraction l'abstraction
si la musique il y a un rapport
organique entre les mathématiques et la
musique c'est pourquoi les enfants
doivent absolument faire de la musique
pour comprendre mieux les mathématiques
la danse c'est le corps comment ils
évoluent dans l'espace mais c'est le
corps par rapport à l'autre corps c'est
cette conscience
importante
on doit avoir de notre corps est donc
avec nos études fait le primaire ou
secondaire on était accompagné par ses
activités là évidemment certains ont mis
l'accent plus sur la musique que sur le
théâtre plus sur la peinture ou la danse
que ses autres visites et des activités
is it est une décision politique un
regard une perception une conception
politique mûrement réfléchie par hbo
libre évidemment par six chefs des deux
relais mais c'est ma peau de me sady
mais surtout je pense celui qui était
derrière ça derrière l'application de ça
c'était ses armes dans salah
qui était un jeune ministre x 5
portefeuilles le six portefeuilles et
qu'ils avaient et ont même été
professeur d'un formation mais il avait
une vision les clubs de cinéma ont été
créés farhad omar au sap ecc a whole
caméras d'arte wells c'était grâce à lui
au bien-être steinway dalo c'est grâce à
lui si les uns tution il a créé des
acision il a créé une génération qui
qui est accompagné non seulement par un
programme
conséquent philosophiquement
spirituellement etc
si on a quand même raté un seul bac at
elle germé c'était des programmes
mûrement réfléchie mais surtout nous
avons été accompagnés par l'activité
artistique culturel chose qui a sauvé
beaucoup de gens s'il ya des gens qui
ont pu réaliser le printemps de terre
tunisien c'est grâce au théâtre scolaire
c'est grâce au théâtre universitaire
s'il ya des gens qui ont pu réaliser le
printemps de la musique tunisienne c'est
grâce à la musique scolaire et c'est
grâce
aux activités annexes adoma s'il ya des
grands sportifs ne sont tous passés par
le sport scolaire donc
et nous pensons
maîtriser notre destinée on peut y
penser on peut faire des plans on peut
faire des stratagèmes mais la réalité ce
qu'on est propulsé axe joyon vers des
horizons vers des cieux qu'on découvre
et
moi je n'ai jamais réellement cherché à
devenir connue elle reconnu le célèbre
et ça je pense que c'est important elle
ratera l'activité artistique
les acteurs et les dans tous les métiers
d'ailleurs meilleure balle chaque fan
des chanteurs
s'il ne se
consacre pas s'il ne se concentre pas à
la règle en fait à
ce titre il faut aimer versa il faut
s'amuser à faire ça et ne pas penser aux
conséquences
ça ce sont des résultats c'est à dire y
est j'y ai fait ma bad d'une manière
automatique donc le problème c'est que
là aussi il est ingrat beaucoup de gens
pensent pouvoir utiliser l'art comme un
temple a signé omar ben ali mabrouk
joyeux notoriété aux reconnaissances au
bas duquel il ne s'est jamais éteinte
dans une dépression
profonde et faire de sorte que les
enfants pratique du théâtre de la
musique de la danse ce n'est pas pour en
créer d forcément des danseurs des
acteurs ou des chanteurs non
c'est pour que quand ils deviennent
ingénieurs on est en fait de théâtre ils
deviennent des mieux les meilleurs
ingénieurs possible quand il devient des
médecins d'ailleurs j'y suis souvent
surpris par des amis médecins qui n'ont
rien à voir avec l'activité artistique
apparemment ils sont chers et pia ils
sont médecins spécialistes gifi silent
hill valley hybride valent bien nous et
ça parce que il a besoin dans son cursus
danse formation d'être aussi dans
l'abstraction c'est pourquoi la musique
doit accompagner les enfants b
évidemment maintenant les choses sont
complètement
confuse et il va falloir que les élites
travail pour converger vers ça
[Musique]
de là
je suis en train de travailler
maintenant sur la création
l'académie artistique pour
l'apprentissage ou les ateliers de
théâtre de la musique
de la danse mais aussi
de l'intelligence artificielle
l'arrêtent nous sommes en retard même si
même si malgré le fait que quand on va à
part les jeunes estime phil belize hall
à bruxelles souvent des jeunes viennent
se faire photographier avec parce qu'ils
me connaissent et j'ai le devoir de leur
demander que fait faux à paris vous être
l'élève
ingénieur informatique
donc il y a eu marre et mêmes des gros
de tunisiens
informaticiens ingénieurs et médecins
malin il y a un potentiel réel c'est
grâce en grande partie grâce à un esprit
je salue c'est un art qui est aussi un
homme qui a fait 9 av l'aco hachey
l'enclos sam est aussi talent et j'ai
que notre ami rosberg et mark des années
relève marc gaubert a plu presque
médiocre et un boulanger de
l'informaticien donc il ya des
potentiels feu l'informatique actuelle
pourquoi ne pas aller et encore enfoncer
le clou pour avoir des des enfants enfin
mon fils n'est plus aux enfants et les
adolescents et des enfants en huit ans
qu'ils savent faire le caudines on est
en retard de deux guerres
épistémologique pour ça paradoxalement
on est bien notre potentiel et et et est
immense pour que la tunisie soit un pays
là où l'intelligence artificielle
arrive à gérer les affaires de l'état
saint pierre la relation des relations
administratives les machins on sait le
faire nous serons le vert donc est là
pour les enfants je suis en train aussi
de réserver pas par là les ateliers
théâtre de musique lala de sport
après les handicapés parce que femme
année sera vraiment notre département al
madani qui mentionnait tu fais un
travail immense à la liesse aux cris de
mcgill à la baule
j'en fais partie enfin je souhaite rien
en faire toujours partie donc
accompagner les enfants dès leur jeune
âge
par une formation artistique
sportive
alain arnaud leclerc à demain
malheureusement leur lyneham l'eau
l'année alors elle donne à citer âge à
la remarquable à lesmo hâtif et locaux
aux halles les maux par les mots au lait
de quoi rendre bélâbre taille qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça ça veut dire que je
comprends parfaitement pourquoi est ce
que l'expérience pédagogique finlandaise
est la plus avancée dans le monde parce
que mégi bush sera la seconde
c'est de là que l'on faire créatif
pour bourrage de crâne pour sortir des
gens
approximatif ammar aurait d'abord
comment ce nom les enfants viennent
jouer jouer si ludique jouer à quoi joue
au théâtre évidemment en finlande ils
jouent aux lego en l1 parce que quand on
joue au théâtre on ne peut pas nous
raconter n'importe quoi quand on aurait
joué ou à l'astral shakespeare molière
rate c'est quoi une pièce de théâtre
c'est une expérience humaine abouti
pousser jusqu'à sa limite et les faire
le faire rien offert à 7,2 elle que vous
bouffez unis fait tout ce qui nous régit
tout cela la capitale donc
quitté
la
liste où la pub
euripide
aristophane voilà molière olabe notation
que starkiller quai tabarly absolue
c'est pourquoi statistiquement parlant
quand on voit la liste des gens qui sont
partis à dh que venez de citer m max
hoff à des âges il est très rare voire
même rarissime un acte à adam sociologie
olam
activités artistiques ou l'armée de loi
aux larmes les choses qui vous
permettent d'avoir une distance par
rapport à ce qu'on essaye de vous
inculquer c'est à dire par rapport à la
manipulation ceux qui sont manipulés
si souvent
comme ça
donc si ces gens là qui sont facilement
manipulables et l'activité artistique
l'activité culturel sportif et tout ça
olam le jeu le jeu il est où elle nous
on ne peut pas de raconter n'importe
quoi
c'est pourquoi moi je pense qu'il ya
aussi quelque chose à faire pour
l'enseignement en tunisie l'enseignement
ou
misérabiliste bouche mais ça c'est un
problème de moyens mais
c'est caduque car
là-bas
en grisé marché
l'avenir
c'est la même chose évidemment
latéral à la loire accueille l'élite
n'est pas les jeunes à mettre celle ci
en toile et elle tâtonne où la toile est
mal de ski majeur
donc il ya un problème général je pense
que une grande partie de ce problème là
peut être résolu ou par
part
par le fait de faire tout sorte que
l'activité culturelle et l'activité
artistique soit réellement un pain
quotidien le théâtre scolaire la musique
spoiler et c'est vrai j'y tiens parce
que j'y suis dedans maintenant et
j'espère que nous allons et parvenir
voilà en somme ce que je voulais dire je
sais pas si tu vas pas être l'écho sur
le même site mais bon voilà je vous
remercie infiniment aux bravo pour tes
d'aix
[Applaudissements]